the SP rating agency has called it a
selective default rating this as a
selective default I want to go to Matt
Miller who has all the details for his
map that's right selective default Trish
because they're talking only about bonds
that are coming to in 2033 and 2033 we
all know the situation the hedge fund
Elliott has Elliott Management Corp has
been negotiating with Argentina about
debt that it has been that it's been
owed for a long time but recently a
court finally said Argentina has to pay
it back in full it never negotiated that
debt previously but there was a big
group of holdouts the majority of the
holders had renegotiated that debt
restructured that debt long ago and they
were being paid regularly now a judge
has ruled that Argentina cannot pay
those renegotiated debt payments or
those restructured debt payments unless
it also pays Elliott the amount that it
owes Elliott in full and any of the
holdouts in full there are a couple
others besides Elliott so with this
ruling it is missed a five hundred
thirty nine million dollar payment
Argentina has it had until today to make
the payment to Elliott or to come to an
agreement with Elliott its Finance
Minister had been in talks with Paul
singer of Elliott Management Corp they
did not come to an agreement and so they
have blown past this deadline so now
Standard & Poor's considers them in
default of this debt due in 2033 so
that's why it's a selective debt not all
together still making debt payments on
other bonds that it's issued but not on
these
Maiki our economics editor joining us
here as well Matt stay with me
you know Mike is selective default is
this in any way better than what could
have been the outcome no not necessarily
if Argentina doesn't find a way to cure
this very quickly and that is still a
possibility because the meetings are
still going on there is a quasi and most
of these bond contracts called cross to
fall which would allow those who only
restructured bonds to immediately demand
full payment so Argentina could be on
the hook for a lot now that a default
has been declared if they do reach some
agreement in the meantime
that would probably obviate that but
that is the threat hanging over
Argentina right now so it leaves
investors in a pretty poor spot well for
the moment it's an odd situation because
Argentina is on a different time zone
than the u.s. SP apparently working off
of the close of US market and then at
the same time when Bank of embankment
and they're clearing banks they may have
ended because they're holding the money
to to pay the debt but if they were to
cure this if they were to come up with a
settlement tomorrow this all could be
reversed so it isn't clear exactly what
would happen the biggest question right
now is if you hold a credit default swap
on Argentina and if default has been
declared you're going to go to the
International Swaps and Derivatives
Association and ask them to rule that
you get paid what do they do do they
have to wait and see whether or not this
goes through and whether there is an
actual default hey Matt you know I'm
just reading from Bloomberg News here
they spoke with a senior Latin American
economist at Goldman Sachs who's telling
Bloomberg News that there's an
expectation that a deal with holdouts
will still be worked out and he went on
to say an Argentine default is expected
to be short-lived at this point and
shouldn't have any major implication for
the country that's right and actually
you saw today this debt surge in price
so even though they were nearing this
deadline without an agreement the debt
was up ten cents to ninety five and a
half ninety five point five seven cents
in facts on the dollar so that's the
highest this debt has been valued in
three years and that's because investors
expect some sort of agreement now while
on the one hand a selective debt is very
bad especially for the reasons that Mike
points out it can it can trigger some
clauses that allow all the debt holders
including restructured bondholders to
call in all of their chips on the other
hand this is a situation that we've all
been following very closely
everybody's been watching as these
negotiations have taking place
everybody's been watching the court
battles so we all know exactly where
well not exactly but we all know to some
degree where things stand and that's why
with industry analysts saying this could
be
is all very soon the debt hasn't taken
an absolute dive no Mike McKee the real
fear is that you could see some kind of
contagion as a result of this might that
be the case or other emerging markets
gonna struggle in debt markets because
of this selective default rating by S&P
on Argentina well I've talked to a
number of sovereign analysts who follow
Latin America in particular they say no
very few of Argentina's bonds are held
by anybody other than hedge funds at
this point and very few of these
countries have the same sort of problems
Argentina does with its economy as a
matter of fact Ecuador went to market
last week and sold out its sovereign
offering without any problems in New
York so no issue seems to be no
significant issue there it seems at this
point of course the the clauses that got
Argentina in trouble the party pasa or
equal treatment causes largely been
dropped from bond contracts so as long
as people are making their payments that
doesn't seem to be the issue now the
question going forward here is is can
Argentina reach a deal it doesn't look
like Argentina wants to deal with the
holdouts but it does look like they may
do some sort of legerdemain where banks
in Argentina buy the debt from the
holdouts if they agree and then they go
to the judge and say please lift the
stay let us say everyone else the
default is cured and then we'll pay the
banks in the long run it's a complicated
process but it might work if the
holdouts get their full about Mike let
me ask you about the timing and although
they say you did mention of course the
time difference between us and Argentina
and that there was a sense that we
needed to wait for the US markets to
close before this was announced in terms
of a deal that could potentially be
worked out how long might it take well
they're obviously working under the gun
now with this S&P rating downgrade
hanging over them there was a feeling
that they could get it done today if all
parties would agree but it hasn't
happened so there seem to be some sort
of sticking point and from what I
understand going on in the talks the
holdouts are still concerned about
making sure they actually do get paid
before they reach any kind of agreement
with Argentina and that they don't trust
the Argentine's because they've held out
for so long against paying